you're at can I would say can or con I
don't know okay
so I go can you go can ya champ when you
were at con I believe it's called you
call it and II III just avoid it France
film thing that French film you're at
the French film thing yeah and you you
go there and you've got to do the red
carpet yeah and suddenly you come down
with a bad bad case of appendicitis
I had attack you know it was worse than
Labor like I had just had Santi like
eight months before that and then I was
in can I landed um I landed in con I
landing counts in about four hours after
I landed I started having pain and I
thought I ate like sketchy Fisher's and
I was like I was a plain food and then
it just like got worse and worse and
worse and and I was like oh my gosh I'm
having an appendicitis yeah because I
web and indeed it so I did you wet yeah
you've diagnosed yourself on web oh yeah
oh yeah yeah cuz I first I thought it
was gas but it wasn't and then I was
like web and being it and it was like if
you put your hand here and your thumb
here and you push down I went oh oh my
gosh and so I get rushed to the hospital
and I get there and I'm like I'm having
appendicitis very precise and they were
like okay well you don't have a fever I
didn't have a fever
they're like your Bloods normal it's
probably Guyana logical it's probably
like a cyst burst or an ovaries turn and
so they I was like no no I'm having an
episode
there's no people and then he was like
they sent me down to gynecology they
look she's like no I think you have an
appendicitis and I was like I know wow
that was intense for me yeah
and I'm Andy Roddick and I'm saying it
French yeah yeah that was yeah no and
and so finally I got emergency surgery
and and I and you know you don't need it
here's the crazy thing you don't need
the the appendix no you do not and I'm
glad we don't need it I couldn't believe
this you have the operation
they remove it you're supposed to stay
in bed for a couple of days in a
hospital you still go and do the red
carpet oh yeah
almost immediately yeah we have a
picture of you just after having your
appendix removed it was opening night a
can and they're like you've seen
hospitals like no I have a really good
dress I'll be damned if I'm not wearing
this dress tomorrow night yeah I had the
IV was doing hair makeup they were doing
my hair and makeup they put the dress on
me and I was like and it's like three
minutes the red carpet in can is
literally three much it's just a short
walk so short right and you don't talk
to anybody's just photos so I was like I
said that's why I'm standing up so
straight cuz I'm in pain I'm like I've
never had the best BAM look that that's
insane I mean that's addiction and I got
back in the car and I went back and
collapsed in my thing but the pictures
beautiful yeah you've got a beautiful
picture out of it and it's all about